he has like 99
um
magical names or something like that 99
special names one of them is the great
deceiver right
it's because that's who satan is saying
is regarded as the greatest of deceivers
you know and
ironically muslims don't see that
oh my god oh my gosh
daniel in the house and donated two
dollars
uh and someone else said that the mersa
aisha was through revelation wahi if i
recall correctly australia was one who
ordained it whatever allah ordains is
pure 100 that's the thing about morality
uh you can't
definitively say anything unless you're
you have revelation from god that's the
only time you can wholesomely say this
is objectively true
so when you're dealing with religion it
makes no sense to make a moral argument
unless you can prove your religion to
begin with and this is the problem i
think a lot of christians have they
presuppose their religion and assume
that we have to as well but no they have
to justify it and maybe we could talk a
little bit more about that so
brother danny hakeekucha i know you saw
the video i think what i'm gonna do is
play the rest of it there's a few
minutes for the stream and then we'll
get back and we'll talk about some of
the points beavers right there he has
like 99
um
magical names or something like that 99
special names one of them is the great
deceiver right
because that is who satan is saying is
regarded as the greatest of deceivers
you know and ironically muslims don't
see that they don't see that right a lot
of them will say false right like if
they're in the chat or you know a false
fall they say fall you know why they say
false one they could be lying
intentionally knowing that they are
lying because again it's permissible in
islam or two
it is because they haven't read the
quran because
most muslims are uneducated on the quran
the clip that i just played um
is uh extraordinarily funny one in my
opinion uh because he used the uh god is
the great deceiver in the quran argument
after saying god has 99 magical names
like this is some fairy tale um and then
he went on to um to say that most
muslims actually don't know the quran
and they intentionally lie because it's
a part of the religion so you see that
he just went to like
islamwiki.com.net or whatever and
looked at the most
common uh arguments so
if there's anything you want to talk
about first daniel inshallah we can
definitely jump to those things if not
then why don't you talk about the whole
misconception of allah being the
greatest deceiver versus greatest
planner where the argument comes from
and so on and so forth
so this is a common argument that's used
by
christian apologists
but it's completely nonsensical like you
don't even need to know the bible
or anything about christianity to
recognize that this is a ridiculous
bad faith argument from christians
uh because allah is deceiving those who
are deceivers themselves those who
engage in deception and those who commit
injustice
are the ones that are going to be
deceived
because they're delusional in their
rejection of allah rejection of
god and islam and they want to create
mischief in the earth they want to trick
the believers and deceive them and they
think that they can trick or deceive
allah their creator
this is their mentality
but
it's
it's very just and very fitting that
this is the tables are turned on them
and in fact they're the ones who are
deceived
so what is what is the problem with this
like what is the moral problem with this
if someone is immoral and if someone is
uh dishonest and someone is committing
all kinds of
uh crimes trying to create bloodshed and
mischief in the land
then it's completely immoral even from
an atheist perspective or christian
perspective or jewish hindu perspective
that that person deserves a taste of his
own medicine
right
so
even on its face like this objection
against islam
is completely dishonest and in bad faith
like they're taking like the worst most
uncharitable reading
of the quran in order to
um
make this kind of criticism but we can
go further because in the in the bible
itself there are examples where
uh
god is quoted
as
deceiving as wanting to deceive and lie
to people
like this is explicit in
not only the old testament but also the
new testament
so some references for you in first
kings
chapter 22 verse 20
uh it starts and the lord said who will
entice ahab
into attacking
ramoff gilead and going to his death
there one suggested this and another
that finally a spirit came forward stood
before the lord and said i will entice
him
by what means the lord asked and the
spirit says i will go out and be a lying
spirit in the mouths of all of his
prophets
you will
that's what the spirit said and then god
says you will succeed in enticing him go
and do it
so god is authorizing this spirit to go
lie
in order to entice and to deceive and
trick
so this is one example in first kings
another example in second thessalonians
chapter 2 verse 11 for this reason god
sends them a powerful delusion
so that they will believe the lie
so how much more explicit can you be
about god sending lot
basically god is lying to people
which is not in islam
allah doesn't lie
to humanity deceiving someone in context
of the quran means that it's their own
self-delusion that allah that god allows
them to continue to be deluded
and and that's how they get mixed up
that's how they trip over themselves as
evil people but this in these verses
it's like god is just going and sending
lies
according to them according to the bible
in jeremiah chapter 4 verse 10 then i
said ah sovereign lord how completely
you have deceived this people and
jerusalem by saying you will have peace
when the sword is at our throats
so again there was uh
this
peace that was supposed to happen
but according to jeremiah the sovereign
lord lied or deceived people
when there was no peace there was just
war and swords at the throats
so i mean we can go into the commentary
on this and the commentary confirms this
interpretation like all of the
traditional christian commentaries will
confirm that yeah sometimes god
according to the bible will deceive
people and outright lie to them
and yeah they'll have like a certain
kind of way to explain why that's okay
but
at the end of the day it's deception
it's it's deceiving people it's lying to
people
and it's it's explicit in the bible so
how can you
criticize islam when islam is not in the
quran it's not even at that level
so that's you know i don't know if you
guys have any thoughts on that i i'm
honestly i'm flabbergasted bro i don't
know and like i'm just thinking about
this from dawn's perspective i'm trying
to be respectful as possible but
honestly like
don you're in a bad situation like a
very like every single argument that you
have made has flipped back on you i want
you to understand that every single
argument you've made so far has flipped
back on you we're gonna keep adding to
it not to be spiteful or hateful or
vengeful but to just speak the truth
because that's what muslims are taught
to do so now you have two options
continue in your arrogance and ignorance
and persistentness and achieve literally
nothing and then lose your credibility
as a person as a man or come back be
honest or take take a month to learn
come back and be honest and admit
these were flawed arguments you did it
out of emotion and you have no argument
against islam next thing i want to
mention is he was talking about the name
of allah where we say that allah is the
best of planners and there's this common
for some reasons common argument that
this is translated to the greatest
deceiver
for some reason allahu adam
i'm not sure why but that was the main
argument that i think he was making
and then he makes a very interesting
point it's unrelated because we've dealt
with that it's done and i'm still
flabbergasted by those verses i found a
lot
god
to jerusalem to jerusalem
said they're going to be in a state of
peace and now they're at war with a
sword to their neck this is god's people
come on man
but side note he said that muslims don't
know the quran
he said muslims don't know the quran and
it always needs interpretation that
every time you buy a quran it comes with
all these footnotes
because like there are footnotes at the
bottom and so on and so forth
and he uses this as kind of an argument
against the quran for some reason that
oh you can't just read it for yourself
you wanna you wanna play it or
i already played that part oh okay yeah
yeah
so yeah so i i mean
planning
because
um
which is the use like in in certain ayat
that's the word that's used the fern
uh
meaning allah or or allah says for
example
uh in the third chapter of the quran
verse 54 when makaroo
they plotted
it's not plan is not exactly right
translation for that
because it's like
is
a kind of deceptiveness like conspiring
they conspired
uh to do something wrong
and um so this is what i was referring
to allah is saying in this verse in the
quran that they plotted they planned
they tried to deceive and then allah
okay also
plotted against them or not in you know
it's
it's not like allah is planning because
allah is all-knowing god is all-knowing
he's all wise he already knows about
their plans he already knows about their
plots
but that's like the foolishness of
someone who thinks that he can deceive
and like work against
the work against god's plans
and christians have this a similar
expression like god works in mysterious
ways
right so god what that means is that
things happen you think that things are
going to happen in a certain way in life
and then something else happens that you
didn't expect
and god works in mysterious ways and
that's the way that
um
these disbelievers or those who are
trying to fight against allah and his
messenger sallallahu those who are
trying to deceive the believers they
think that they have the upper hand they
think that they're in control
and that's what gives them the
confidence to scheme and connive and
deceive
and do this kind of makru
but in fact it's allah who's in control
allah is the one who's all-powerful
allah is the one who is going to turn
their plots against them and that's so
purely justified that's purely you know
we can see the superiority of that
and and the beautiful nature of that
that's how allah operates
um and so this is not something that is
foreign to christianity it's not foreign
to judaism in fact according to the
bible uh their understanding of god goes
much further
than just retaliation or um
reciprocity between
um these two like
giving the deceivers and the criminals
they're just desserts
one hundred percent
because actually i didn't know that
about makker and the actual definition
and often you do see it translated as um
you know they plan on the law plans and
allows the best of planners so
for being you know completely
transparent and honest about it and i
think honestly it's probably one of the
best explanations of it that i've heard
so mm-hmm
if i do have anything to add before we
move on and play the rest of the clip
um
i'm gonna be honest bro i have something
to add but it's gonna be leading into a
side tangent but someone sent me a
screen recording of him in a stream
claiming that hinduism is a monotheistic
religion bro and i don't even want to
get it
as a christian he has to as a christian
he has to because they believe in
brahman as far as i know and then that
one god is broken down to millions of
other gods
and that's why he has to say that uh
it's monotheistic to some degree
talk fell
boring and hard to read one and two it
requires wait it is incredible most
muslims are uneducated on the quran that
is just a fact
it is incredibly boring and hard to read
he just says
am i can they hear me bro yeah yeah they
can hear you yeah for anyone wondering
where angel is brother angel is
traveling at the moment so inshallah he
will join us next session inshaallah and
everyone
for the super chats may allah bless you
all immensely uh everyone send this
stream to someone else and write the
words oh my god this is crazy uh to get
them to click on it i want it to double
in sha allah
so viral
i want you guys to take and he just said
the quran
is incredibly boring to read that's how
i know he hasn't read the bible because
he would literally eat his words if he
actually read the bible
it's literally
like
there's like hundreds of thousands of
words in the bible bro
bro the amount of books you need of
interpretation and
explanations and all this don't even get
me started yeah and it's insane i'm just
gonna play the rest of the clip
the one and two it requires
interpretation it didn't quite like you
can't read the quran on your own
even in quran you go out to buy it will
come with
like
notes and interpretation notes if you
just try to read it on your own and you
read it plainly often times they'll say
you're reading it wrong
and that's one of the biggest arguments
that they will have when you try to
bring up errors in the quran for
instance dior
why don't you eat pork
because
the filth
the
what the you know i know i just said a
lot of really harsh things about the
religion the false religion
and i know in islam you are trained to
to
one because you don't have truly have
the holy spirit within you so you don't
really have grace and kindness and mercy
in your heart you feel me
um which is a state that i'm very
familiar with i know what if
okay so i'm not going to play the rest
of this clip all i'm going to say is
that he basically goes on to say that
before christianity he was at a point
where he was so angry at little petty
things that people would do that he
would have thoughts of if i could snap
my fingers and this person would be dead
and i got away with it clean i would do
it um and he's talking about this kind
of state before christianity and his his
boys are kind of like you know what the
hell do you want bro what the hell are
you talking about i've never felt that
and he asked like he tried to reason
with him oh you've never felt that and
they're like no
yeah so i know i think it's because the
most the most concerning thing too is he
says i would have i would have ended
them i would have offed them over dumb
stuff too over petty stuff too and
daniel you saw the clip so
hashtag christian values if that's what
you think is representing christian
values then i have nothing else to say
well to be fair he says that that's what
he how he felt before he became
christian right yeah that's true he's
not saying
i mean i don't necessarily see anything
wrong with that statement i mean that's
a
personal revelation about his own mental
state and maybe he you know had an anger
problem
but if you know he's
moved past that because of christianity
okay i mean
i i can't really fault him for trying to
improve
but
it's a interesting revelation about his
mental state in the past
so so let's talk about something a
little more uh related to religion islam
he mentioned that and he kind of used
this as a it's what seemed to be a
negative talking point about islam that
when you get a quran you always have sub
notes you cannot understand it on your
own you always need some kind of
interpretation needs to be interpreted
do you want to talk about a little bit
why do muslims need interpretation
well it's
revelation the quran is not meant to be
read like by itself in the abstract
um obviously every muslim can go and
open the quran and read it and
non-muslims can open the quran and read
it
and you will definitely
many have converted to islam
just by reading the quran by itself even
one of my close friends
who's a professor now at a university he
became muslim just because he opened the
mosque and he started reading through
sort of bakara the longest chapter of
the quran he read surat al-fatiha then
he went to
the second chapter and about you know
maybe 60 verses within surat al-baqarah
like very early in the first juzz he
said to himself i can't deny that this
is from god
like it just hit him so hard
um and he and he was a christian he was
like a
very devout believing christian he
believed in god and
he thought he was a christian and then
he read the quran and it just
became obvious it was obviously the
truth when when he read it and many
christians that i know who became muslim
have the same experience when they
opened the quran
some like i have another friend who
became muslim he was christian
and he just
opened the must-have and
basically
he landed on surat al-ikhlas
which every muslim learns as a child
say allah is one
that was the first thing he read from
the quran and it just hit him you know
really hard in the heart
that wow you know this is
because the quran is not like other
kinds of literature like you can read
the bible
you can read other kinds of scripture in
hinduism or you can read the talmud
which is the oral torah which jews also
believe is from god as revelation
given to moses
none of those those all read like you
know books that in literature that human
beings write
um but the quran
is just different like it has a
different feeling to it and
people even the enemies of islam will
will note it uh and you can see this
within the academic study of the quran
it's not really poetry
uh because the arabs of of the time of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam in
the seventh century and prior they had a
long tradition of poetry
but the quran is not like that
and it's also not like prose like you're
relaying a story or you're relaying
historical events or you're relaying
like a myth like mythology
it's not like that either it's just
something completely unique and
completely different
and
this will strike the non-muslim the
atheist and
uh even christians so i think when he
you know noted like he clearly has
noticed like the quran is different he
wants to spin it as if it's a bad thing
but
what muslims know is that well it's
because it's unique because it's
actually from god
it's not the inspired word of god it's
not you know like this
uh long convoluted history of the bible
with all of its revisions and edits and
contradictions
it's not like that it's something
unique it's something amazing it's a
miracle
so alhamdulillah that we're muslim and
we
have this gift
and we're sharing it with the with the
world alhamdulillah
so something actually i've wanted to
discuss um to the audience of the people
especially christians when it comes to
like for example the bible versus the
quran a lot of christians presuppose the
bible is true especially people like
young dawn he said himself on the last
stream where everything kind of started
i don't need to defend the bible and
then when sheikh man asked
um you know where do you get your
beliefs from he says the bible he's like
well how do you know it's just breathing
and he's like i don't need to defend it
so i was like you know you can't
you know you can't claim such a thing
but they expect us to prove our religion
and go against all these weird
accusations they have so if somebody
let's say young don came on the stream
and he's like
i how do i know that the quran actually
is miraculous
how would you
go about educating him on that
well there's different aspects of the
miraculousness
of the quran but i mean first i think i
find it like hilarious that he says he
doesn't need to defend
the bible i think this is just something
that he like a talking point that he got
from his handlers like it's clearly
clear that he's being trained
if if that's the kind of thing he's
saying
so it's like okay we we're not like on
that stage of your training yet young
don like just if they bring up the bible
anything from the bible just say you're
not going to defend it like that's such
a
nonsensical answer yeah
uh but when it comes to the the quran um
there are different aspects to its
miraculousness um one of
what a lot of people will talk about is
for example the
language of the quran and the eloquence
of the quran
within the quran
and this there are many commentaries on
this i think what
really was the most uh notable thing
that in my life
was you know i i went to harvard and for
my undergrad in college and there was a
christian arab here's lebanese
who was also in in the same class as me
freshman year
at harvard and we were talking about
religion and comparing the quran and the
bible
and he said you know his father is also
a christian lebanese christian
and who's like an expert in literature
and so he's talking about his father and
he admitted at what one point in our
conversation that his father actually
loves the quran
even though he's a christian
he loved the quran and i was like well
why if he's a christian
and he loves the quran why doesn't he
become muslim
and this lebanese guy was saying that
well he recognizes that the quran is
from god he recognizes that because why
why why does he recognize that because
of the language
like he's an expert in literature
he knows that the quran like no one can
match no human being can match that
level of eloquence of the quran
and so he
for that reason believes that it's from
god he just can't accept it like for
personal reasons like something is
blocking him from accepting it as the
truth
so i thought that was very interesting
testimony testimony
um i think that this uh miraculous
nature of the quran it's something that
you can't really express
or even a lot of muslims won't even be
able to recognize themselves because
most muslims are not going to reach that
level of expertise with the arabic
language
you can study arabic for years
and not reach a level of mastery to
appreciate all of the nuances that make
the quran the superior
as you get you know further and further
in your arabic studies you get more of a
sense of it
and you get a more of a taste of it and
how the quran is different and superior
but so it's it's hard to convey that to
people who don't speak arabic or they
don't they haven't mastered arabic
or they you know they're just not
muslims so
i'm not sure if that's the best point to
really emphasize to
non-muslims i think one
aspect of the miraculousness of the
quran that we can
justify for non-muslims to be able to
verify themselves is the preservation of
the quran
and this is something that is unmatched
in any religion like no religion with
their scripture comes close
other religions they can't really
attribute their books to the supposed
founders of their religion
um there's no evidence there's no like
hard evidence
that for example you can date the oldest
biblical manuscripts
and they're just
you know when it comes to the new
testament it's like the earliest
manuscripts can only be dated to within
150 years after
jesus
150 years or when it comes to
moses and the old testament or the
hebrew bible
that's even you know it's they can't
even get within
uh a thousand years
of moses they can't they don't have any
manuscript
that exists that they know of that can
be dated to the time of
when when moses according to judaism
purportedly lived
so if you can't get the manuscript or
you can't get the earliest manuscripts
anywhere close to the supposed founder
of the religion
then
how can you have confidence that the
book that you have
the hebrew bible is what actually came
from the founder of the religion how can
you tell that
um or uh hinduism like you can't with
the vedas
the vedas you can't get the oldest
manuscripts are
thousands three thousand four thousand
years after the founders
allegedly of hinduism allegedly lived
and and wrote the vedas
so this is like there's no religion
that's even close but when it comes to
the quran
the oldest manuscripts of the quran
are dated academically
objectively to within the lifetime of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam
that is that is significant why because
we can open those manuscripts
uh and read what they what's written
there and match that with what muslims
today
read and recite and teach of the quran
that is
huge that is because if you think that
god sends revelation
right that's what christians believe
that's what jews believe
hindus have have a slightly different
understanding of revelation buddhists
have a slightly different understanding
of revelation but let's just focus on
judaism and christianity they believe
jews and christians believe that god
sends revelation in some form or fashion
whether it's inspired word of god or
tablets being sent to moses or whatever
god sends that revelation to guide
humanity
but if god is sending that revelation
wouldn't he preserve it like wouldn't it
be something that's preserved
up to this time
so that people can follow that
revelation and and practice it
the fact that that has not happened
in judaism and christianity is a is a
big mark against those religions
actually or those scriptures actually
being from
god
but in islam we actually meet like that
that bar
islam the quran actually meets that
basic requirement the basic logical
requirement
for being like a true religion in our
times
uh how can you be a true religion and
have the scripture have the revelation
of god when you can't even source it to
the founder of the religion this the
alleged founder of the religion speaking
you know in academic terms yeah so islam
is the only religion that meets that
uh standard
so that's that's something miraculous
and and we're not even talking about
memorization
because that's a different whole
different aspect of it because we know
that the quran has been transmitted
primarily through
through memorization and recitation
and
muslims have their children memorize the
entire quran my own children are
memorizing the quran we're trying to get
them to complete theirs
that's what preserves the quran
but if that's not enough for you we also
got the receipts
we also got you know all of the all the
script all the texts
the manuscripts the folios they've been
preserved they're in various museums
and they've been dated carbon dated to
within the lifetime of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
and there's also a lot of geological
discoveries because
um
muslims would write quran
not just on like
parchment or vellum like
animal hide leather they would also
write on rock
they would also write on pottery or uh
they would
other places that
can last
you know over centuries and now
archaeologists are discovering like
these kinds of inc carvings within stone
in the arabian peninsula and they can
date those also to within the lifetime
of the prophet sallallahu islam or very
early after
and that's further proof and evidence
but you don't have anything analogous to
that within judaism
or christianity and definitely
definitely not the
vedic religions like hinduism and
buddhism and so forth yeah 100 100
and uh if that is not enough for someone
to accept the stem that has to at least
be enough for someone like don to
have a huge doubt casted over his belief
and the question as to why he is a
christian and i think that's something
that's very uncomfortable for a lot of
people to ask themselves and to try and
sit down with themselves and answer it
but for any belief you have it is
necessary i want to expand on that point
a little bit
um just so it's a little more understood
most of the manuscripts for the new
testament uh that we have are from the
ninth century
the ninth century yeah
exactly
and anything we do have from like the
second century third century is like the
size of a credit card and the shape of a
triangle so like there's probably more
information on my credit card than there
is on on those
things and there's this book i have here
i point out every single time i talk
you can't read it but it says the five
gospels it has the gospel of mark
matthew luke and john and also the
gospel of thomas which i know christians
say is not canonical but still a
historical document to some extent and
you might be wondering why am i bringing
out this giant book it's because they
took every single verse that is reported
in the gospels that jesus said and they
rank them
and they color code them as well
they put in red letters like this at the
top things jesus most likely said they
put in pink letters things he probably
said they put in gray letters things he
probably didn't say and they put in bold
black letters things jesus definitely
did not say it was a group of new
testament scholars that got together and
voted on every they voted on every
single verse in these five gospels and i
just want you to take a quick look and
tell me what color you see
most of
black mostly black black black black
black you know why ninety-five percent
of the verses in here were graded black
by or were great completely fabricated
and authentic by the jesus seminar uh
and other scholars new testament
scholars that is because
you cannot in any way shape or form
link the new testament back to jesus
christ peace and blessings be upon him
and adding to that point
with all the differing views
they had at the time
how would you know that this
articulation this understanding of jesus
was the accurate one you had the ebay
knights you had i think the monarchist
thing is the name
and you had subordinationists you have
unitarians as well amongst those groups
you have so many different groups of
people how do you know that this
co equal eternal trinity that you have
today that came 300 years later and it
was voted upon
at the council of nicaea how do you know
that is the correct understanding you
don't
and that i think is another big problem
that they have to deal with i can expand
on it more but inshallah i think we
should move on i have some super chats
here quickly
i mean we don't even have to go back to
like the ebia nights and the marcia
nights
because those were different uh groups
um you know within
two or three centuries of jesus
but
um what about all of the changes and
distortions to
uh christianity and christian christian
theology christology
uh
like in the past 200 years over the past
300 years or like this um young don
uh
he's
like following what evangelical
christianity like he's born again
christian like where what are the roots
of evangelical christianity
um and why should you be evangelical
christian as opposed to the hundreds of
other or thousands of other sects with
just in the modern day
and there are some huge differences like
between you know your conception of god
your conception of jesus
is jesus the
son of god is he co-eternal with god is
he this or that so
all of these are like major differences
in theology
um
that don't exist in islam like in islam
you can say oh what are the big
distinctions you have sunni and you have
shia
sunni and shia don't differ like about
oh does god have a son or does god have
like
different uh partners that he works with
or like we don't have those kinds of
uh distinctions in our very conception
of god himself
um so that's that's a big difference
between islam and
christianity for sure
100 100
and one last note i want to mention on
this topic is amongst different opinions
and i think we really are kind of
beating the dead horse here so we'll
move on after this maybe take some
questions and super chats actually there
was a question earlier for you so i'll
read that out in a minute but um there
is actually
it's actually crazy if you think about
it not that we need this as muslims we
don't need this at all but just so
christians kind of understand the kind
of beliefs that were out there there was
an early century
uh early second century or let's just be
fair i say second century
church father named basilides
who iranius writes in his book against
heresies i can find the exact quote for
you if you want
that basilities believed that jesus was
not crucified and that simon
was switched out on the cross and he was
crucified in jesus place while jesus
rose to his father does that sound very
familiar to you does that sound familiar
to you this is second century church
father reported by iranians in his book
the great book uh against heresies where
he talked about i think the uh ibn
knights and a bunch of other groups as
well
this conception or this this belief
was articulated by a second century
church father
when islam came in seventh century
arabia and the prophet had no access to
even the bible the five the four gospels
you have today let alone the work of one
random church father in the second
century
like
just to know that historically that kind
of belief was there to begin with from a
church father in the second century
sit with that think about it i'm gonna
read this question i'm gonna take a two
minute break for myself uh unless you
guys have anything you want to add
before i read this question oh no i just
want to say denying that is like denying
any rationale like there's
there's nothing to say after that yeah
yeah but uh i mean you can't really
expect unfortunately with these
christian apologists you can't expect
any kind of consistency
um it's just really
they
will go to all kinds of lengths to deny
like the obvious contradictions the
obvious inconsistencies on any of these
issues that we're talking about whether
we're talking about like violence
whether they're talking about like
marriage like minor marriage whether
we're talking about authenticity of text
whether we're talking about theology
preservation of scripture
like they really have nothing that they
can criticize islam with and
i mean this is a big point also that we
should
make is that well why are like in in
an earlier clip
this young don is saying that islam is
like the religion of satan
islam is muslims are the foot soldiers
of of satan and i find that so funny
when you have a christian saying that
and why do they say that why are they
focused on islam because in the whole
world there are only two religions that
have any kind of positive understanding
of jesus christ
one is christianity and the other is
islam
all other religions are either neutral
with with regards to christianity or
they actually uh demonized jesus christ
um
and
that religion is judaism so there there
are
there's at least one religion that
actually has demonized jesus christ in
like very
disturbing and shocking ways what they
write about jesus in their texts but
these christians want to criticize
muslims and islam even though we have
like the most positive
view of jesus christ so how does that
make any sense how how can you claim to
be consistent when you want to demonize
islam but you have nothing to say about
these other religions that are either
neutral like they think that christ was
just a random nobody
or they think that he was like a
sorcerer polytheist spawn of of satan
like you have nothing to say about those
religions but you want to focus on islam
i'll tell you why i'll give you the
reason it's because
islam is the only religion
that
has not liberalized islam is the only
religion that hasn't sold out to like
the modern liberal
world yeah whereas all of these other
religions like hinduism judaism buddhism
uh even confucianism
shintoism they've all liberalized
they've all adopted these kinds this
liberal understanding of human value
human rights etc
and islam is the only holdout islam is
the only religion that says no we're not
going to sell out our religion we're not
going to change we're not going to
change our teachings we're not going to
distort it because why because we know
it's from god and we're gonna practice
it
you guys are changing so christians on
some level either explicitly or
especially these apologists they
recognize that on some level and they
see islam as a threat like islam if you
compare christianity in its reformed
modernized liberalized secularized form
today
to islam it's it's obvious that
christians have sold out
christians have restored their teachings
and there's a there's like all the
receipts are there when we when you look
at the 19th century at the beginning of
the enlightenment and the pressure that
was put on the church the catholic
church as well as protestants as well as
orthodox to update and change their
teachings to outlaw certain things
that historical record is all there
so this this
makes them feel threatened it makes them
feel like they have to go after the big
boys you know with muslims they have to
go after
the
you know the true religion they don't go
after hinduism they don't go after
judaism they don't go after buddhism
because th those they're all in one
group like a bunch of liberalized
reformed religions islam is the last man
standing so that's
it's obvious why they will focus their
energy and their anger hatred and
jealousy on muslims and islam yeah 100
that is that is very true and it's
unfortunate but uh alhamdulillah i think
muslims are resilient enough you know
to uh to withstand that and it's funny
because you you mentioned something and
answered the question that somebody
asked before i got a chance to read it
out they said question for daniel in
contemporary society do you think
christianity is learning more and more
is is leaning more and more towards
secular thinking and i think you
completely answered that wholeheartedly
so i think uh masud brother you got your
answer there inshaallah
i am gonna take a two minute break
myself you guys insha allah will
continue and uh continue to educate the
viewers here in sha allah one question i
want to ask daniel because we didn't get
a chance to actually fully watch the
clip with you here live we know that you
took a look at it earlier on uh while
i'm gone
you and phi can talk about what were
your initial reactions to it you know
what were your initial thoughts when you
heard some of the claims of maybe the
things we didn't get a chance to discuss
with you
uh yeah sure um and daniel bro you could
hear me right yeah i can hear you okay
all right carry on
uh yeah i think that
i mean there are a lot of things that
uh that i saw from the clip like he's
bringing up the age of aisha radiology
it's like a standard christian
bulimic but it's like such a again like
a weak claim because they have the same
thing in the bible like even
more explicit
and i mean i think that when it comes to
the age of aisha like we have to be
clear like
yeah there might be some kind of
question about okay was she
seven or six or
nine or ten
but there's no actual uh
view or opinion in the in the tradition
the islamic tradition that says she was
like 18 or 17.
that's a 100 modern view
so i think we have to be like very clear
about that like okay
just because it's not like
there's not like a birth certificate
that says that aisha was born on this
month on this day and this year then
therefore it's open she could have been
uh much older no like no one seriously
thought that she was much older like
that's generally the age range
but again like this is not
an issue it's not an issue like uh in
the clip
the uh young don is saying that oh well
muslims have no problem with minor
marriage
because they have satan in their hearts
or jesus has not entered their hearts i
think is what he said
so i mean if that's the case
then
jesus was not in the heart of christians
themselves
because christians throughout history
accepted a minor marriage and practiced
minor marriage
throughout their societies throughout
their um throughout europe minor
marriage was practiced and even in canon
law canon law which is
um you know the most like it's the
analog to phil basically in islam like a
fake tradition but in canon law within
christianity
um the age of consent was just 12 years
old
um
so that like the same kind of concept of
minor marriage
um
daughters being married off young
that is something that has been
practiced by christians by jews by
muslims by pretty much every single
civilization
prior to
modern liberal reforms have have
practiced this
um so
yeah i just have a hard time
understanding like what is their
uh complaint like okay if you want to
just take whatever you believe now like
young don
himself
he converted right so he accepted an
entire religion that
means that he for many years of his life
was living completely ignorant about
certain things he was just a product of
his culture product of social forces
around him and then he discovered this
religion and he became christian
so that should give him in a sense that
you can be very wrong
about the nature of
reality for large portions of your life
before you discover something that you
then believe is true and we should all
have this kind of sense that a lot of
the things in the world around us
that we
that seem to be true that seem to be
right that seem to be moral
uh may actually turn out to be wrong
might turn out to be unjust may turn out
to be immoral
and other things that we thought were
immoral might turn out to be perfectly
fine and moral
that that's what it means to be like a
humble person or to understand that
we to a certain extent everyone is the
product of their environment and a
product of their culture so this idea
that it's some kind of
huge moral injustice it's like a crime
uh like it's completely oppressive and
abusive
for a man to marry a uh pubescent miner
at those age at those ages that's
something that is purely a product of
the past
not even necessarily 200 years but more
like 100 years or 50 years in one
particular part of the world
so
it's like a very
when i can more understand atheists
making this type of argument against
islam
because they just believe in the
morality of the now
like whatever happens now whatever we
believe now according to the liberal
state
okay for a hundred years
muslims christians atheists believe that
sex between two men is completely
immoral and completely wrong but now in
the past 10 years we we believe that
it's a beautiful thing that we should
all celebrate
like that change
is only 10 years
old so if you're an atheist and you
really believe that morality works like
that like it can constantly update
okay that's a separate discussion and
there are separate arguments that you
can make
against that but if you're a christian
you don't believe
in that right if you're a christian you
don't believe that values are just
constantly updating you believe in a
tradition you believe in
you know the morality of prior
christians whether it's like the early
church fathers or whether it's like the
the
papal tradition or the catholic church
or the orthodox church you believe in a
tradition
so you can't just make
judgments on the basis of your cultural
milieu like your cultural context and
sensibilities that have only come onto
the scene now
within the past 10 years or 50 years or
100 years you have to look at the entire
history you have to look at the entire
tradition and you have to stand by that
to a certain extent and defend it
because if you start saying that no
this is something so immoral and so
wrong this kind of practice of minor
marriage then you're basically saying
that your entire
uh history is full of pedophiles
your entire religion is a is a religion
of
you know pedophiles because they were
practicing this
so an atheist like atheists are fine
with throwing the entire
past like all of this history under the
bus
they're fine with that
that has its own like problems and
irrationality
uh but christians
how can you make that kind of argument
it's so it's completely self-defeating
but they just don't want to admit it
like
yeah it's like it's a joke basically
like these kinds of christian
apologetics is just a joke like one joke
after another it's
and i've debated christians before and
um like david wood was probably the
biggest apologist i debated and
you just can't keep up with the
contradictions that
they spew
yeah and uh just for everyone's
reference here you can find the debate
between daniel hakichu and david wood
online you can find debates between him
and many other people whether they be
christians or atheists or liberal
secularists whatever it might be you can
find them online you can also find just
this for like young don you can find
sheikh uthman
versus someone you want to watch after
discussing sheikh man david wood you can
find that debate or those debates online
as well you can find many muslims
discussing with even even muhammad hijab
clowning david yeah many muslims shabir
ali many many muslims
debating all three of the people you you
mentioned apus david wood nabil qureshi
shabir ali debated nabil khrushchev he
passed away so like there's no recent
debates but you know before he passed
away you see the debates there you see
david wood
debated by muhammad hijab
of man i believe
also debated against did you debate
against a plus or was he too scared to
do that yeah so that happened yeah yeah
he started calling it like pikachu in
that stuff
my man had a whole mental breakdown in
the thing with daniel
yeah and um if if you think these people
are good to listen to okay go watch the
debates go watch the debates do a live
reaction actually do a live reaction
because i know you won't react to this
life
uh and then see if you you know can
defend whatever they're saying
then when they're in front of a muslim
okay something
oh sorry real quick just a note about
shabirani because a lot of muslims will
follow his debates
but actually he has like a lot of messed
up views like islamically
so i would like be careful just watch it
you can watch his debate if you want i
mean other people have debated
just as good or better than him against
christians but just know in the back of
your mind that he's like definitely not
a orthodox muslim like he has all kinds
of deviant views yeah are you talking
about like
like a recent shabir ali or like
decade two ago shibuya ali because i
think i feel like those are two
well
different
still he's still debating now like he
just had a debate with david with a
couple of weeks ago i think wow i was
not talking about that i was talking
about the the one against i think came
into bill crush like years ago on the
trinity
versus target i think that's what it was
but um i i'm aware of of what you're
talking about some of his um
his his views i don't uh
and you know one one thing i wanted to
say too
is in christianity there's a belief that
priests
cannot have
intercourse daniel you can correct me if
i'm wrong
uh yeah within the catholic church
yeah within the catholic church a lot of
them they talk about how they're married
to god a lot of the the nuns too and
they can't have intimacy so it's
self-imposed celibacy
but the result of the self-imposed
celibacy this this alone should prove
it's not from god rama you can pull up
the link that i i sent you
but this alone can prove that it's not
from god because
if allah created us
he understands us he understands our
nature he understands that we as men and
women have needs
very primal needs and imposing celibacy
is going to do more harm than good
now in islam we restrict that to our
wives and permissible outlets and for
women they're husbands but if you look
at this you just just pull it up bro
it's disgusting
here it's on the screen now
ask me to log in but i won't
yeah if you could read it just that's
blessed all right um
so the the title says
french catholic church personnel
sexually abused 330
000 miners probe finds this the wall
street journal which i don't have a
subscription to so i can only read the
title
yeah i think that um
there's definitely an issue there with
with celibacy and
whether that breeds hypocrisy
because it's like such a
unnatural thing
um to require celibacy um
so
i think a lot of christian groups though
will criticize catholicism for that um
so it's not universal across
christianity
uh just we just have to note that to be
fair and
i also don't
want to like it's obviously appalling
like the amount of child abuse
within the catholic church
um you'll also find it in other
religions
and you'll also find it in secular
institutions um so if we look at the
rates of child abuse and molestation
when it comes to um like just public
schools
um
it's more than the catholic church
i think
it's comparable in terms of like the
total amount is is greater
but the actual rate you know per capita
or whatever is
is equal or more maybe
so i don't have the stats off the top of
my head
but i mean because i don't want
i think that we can criticize
christianity for a lot of things and we
want to be like principled about it but
we also have to recognize that
um the secular system and liberalism is
attacking
all religions
um is attacking and is basically trying
to stamp out religion
and
that again i'm not trying to defend the
catholic church
but we have to kind of recognize that
there is an attempt to subvert the
catholic tradition and
um orthodox christianity and those same
forces are used and those same kind of
arguments are used against muslims
so is it the case that you know some
muslim somewhere has committed a crime
like against a child
yeah of course that's that has happened
is that a reason to you know destroy or
to undermine
our mosques our masajid or our islamic
schools or you know different kinds of
institutions where we teach children
that's what they're trying to do that's
what these liberals are trying to do
with
madrasahs with mosques masajit islamic
schools
they want to kind of point this finger
and say that oh look someone got abused
that means the whole thing is corrupt
that means the whole thing has to be
shut down
and you have to send your kids to the
secular schooling the secular
institution the secular day care
but they
you know downplay or hide the fact that
at these secular institutions at these
daycare centers let's talk about abuse
and molestation in these secular
institutions and public schools every
other day like you can find like some
kind of incident in the local news
happening where a teacher molested a
child
it's not it's not even
it's not something rare
so
like
we should just be like very fair and
even-handed not to defend like
the catholic church or like the cover-up
of abuse because that's also a factor
like they've covered up a lot of this
these molecular cases or they've like
transferred different priests
uh to different locations instead of
holding them accountable for their abuse
but you know let's also keep in mind the
broader factors so that we have like a
more
nuanced critique of like what's
happening
no that was well said
and brother daniel is there anything
else that you want to get out before we
wrap up the stream
yeah sure uh thanks so much for having
me on it's like a pleasure i hope i
didn't like talk too much
no no it was perfect it was it was good
it was necessary and may allah bless you
anyone that made it this far smash the
like button head over to the muslim
skeptic one more time it's the muslim
skeptic three words that's brother
daniel hakiguchi's channel and all the
links are gonna be in the description
anyway rami anything you want to say
wait one thing i want to say sorry wrong
go for it uh
i think that
like i think that there's
a benefit to
someone like young don
becoming more religious becoming like
christian and
even attacking islam there i know it's
it's bad uh it's bottle it's like real
nonsense that he's spewing but there is
a silver lining like there is a positive
what is that the positive is that
muslims also step up their game
and more muslims are like you know
interested in studying like these
details about the quran compared to the
bible about looking at theology looking
at akita basically stepping up our game
that's like a huge benefit and it's much
better than like young don
being like just this musician and making
youtube videos and like promoting uh
secularism purely
and muslims following that
and being fans of that instead muslims
are now like uh you know stepping up
their game becoming more religious
like that's actually something that
people experience muslims experience
like oh you want to insult islam well
i'm going to be even a better muslim i'm
going to pray more i'm going to you know
do more sunnah i'm going to do read more
quran and there's that this kind of hima
that muslims have as a reaction so i
think it's
overall like it might seem contradictory
but
i wanna it would be great i'd much
rather see more musicians more like uh
youtubers and entertainers become
religious christians
that is gonna help like that i think has
a positive impact
on muslims
to react and especially when this this
young don he's not like
spreading this message oh everyone's the
same all religions are the same we need
to hold hands and sing kumbaya it's
actually better that he's attacking
islam and he's saying you know he's
saying this nonsense
so that's maybe that's like my my
perspective but that's how i feel yeah
and i mean you you actually find this a
lot whenever there's like some kind of
an attack or or any big news asked with
islam even if it's in a negative light
you find a lot of people look into it
afterwards like um after the event in i
think in 2001 i won't say what it is but
it has
one number slash another number i'm not
trying to get the platforms right now uh
you know in minecraft that's where it
happened a lot of people looked into
islam afterwards i got the one from
sneako a lot of people looked into islam
afterwards you find a lot of people
actually became muslim after looking to
islam afterwards um so i think this
insha allah has and will benefit
literally thousands of people
alhamdulillah we've consistently had uh
close or over to 2 000 viewers actively
so i think this has been amazing one
last
super chat i'm going to read before we
end the stream when westerners
vacations to their countries is well
documented uh they
um
use little girls and bullies all the
time
uh all the vacation destinations have
receipts uh it's actually very true and
unfortunately we won't talk about it too
much um
um we'll save for another time insha
allah but with that being said
jazakallah daniel is always nice having
you everyone check out our episode i
think we had two actually done with
brother daniel uh in the early
conception of our channel actually so he
was an og uh from the beginning somebody
bro that was like a year ago yeah yeah i
spent a long time ago
so everyone check those out subscribe to
daniel the muslim skeptic and um check
out his website the muslim skeptic.com
correct
muslimskeptic.com
bro
listen super important thing to
piggyback off of what brother daniel
said
this
video is not just intended to
take non-muslims out of ignorance but to
empower muslims too
and to give them knowledge to give them
a lens that they might not have seen or
studied yet and that's why it's
absolutely imperative that anyone that
made it this far please share the video
willahi not for us to get more subs or
this video to get anything else but if
everyone can share it to five people
just imagine how much you can have how
many muslims can be empowered and how
many non-muslims can slip out of
ignorance that's it share this video
like and at the end of the day links in
the description watch the muslim skeptic
watch one message foundation we're all
trying to do the same thing and at the
end of the day we just want you guys to
come to the truth that's it
one hundred percent
faith
may allah bless you inshallah hopefully
we can do this again soon
inshallah
all right so
we're about to end this off thank you
all very much for the super chats i
apologize i could not read all of them
but we do sincerely sincerely appreciate
him i love us to all of us so you guys
help the channel uh keep going keep
running and insha'allah as we grow um
honestly
donating is one thing but spreading the
video and spreading our channel is is a
whole other thing we can insha allah get
bigger
and better um
guests on here inshaallah to help spread
the truth of islam
bigger platform bigger guests and not
just muslim muslims as well so we can
have more of these discussions about
islam with people who are sincere
inshallah we'll be doing sneaker part 2
eventually and again thank you all for
the super chat honestly fired bro
and guys listen super chats help out
they help us tremendously youtube
doesn't pay us as much as you guys think
helps us continue our work but
liking sharing commenting that helps us
more than you guys think and if you
can't do that just make dua for us
institute please keep us in your duas
make dua that we keep spreading the dean
of allah and not making mistakes staying
steadfast gaining knowledge ourselves
and inshallah look forward to in a week
from now on saturday seven days from now
you will see an episode with
sister muslim brooklyn who is an
american
river
who literally grew up in the midwest and
accepted islam in a small town i believe
she said there was not more than 900
people
and
subhanallah was a wonderful story so
stay tuned for that insha allah and with
that being said i think it's safe to end
it off here
assalamu
the prophet saw mentioned that the
bridge between belief and disbelief is
abandoning salah if you're struggling
with your salah right now well we got
the perfect solution for you and that
solution is the adan app this cell phone
we usually have it and is using us
instead of us using it
but with the adana you can use it in
perfect alignment with your life the
adhan app is already used by 40 million
believers around the world why because
it caters to your islamic lifestyle on
top of this a lot of times you get their
eyes
the islamic calendar ramadan
and much more for free so download the
addon up now